airshare sh and then the two a's from
his name so it's just shy
i was trying to think of the most
annoying one would you ask chair
s oh ass chair is that what you said
asher asshair
sure what about just shiren
yeah yeah i think it'll probably be
aaron sharon it's probably the ship name
yeah aaron sharon i think when they get
married he should take her
first name uh yeah
nice yeah i think that or it could be or
it could be like a weird switcheroo
she's like i'm sharon he's like i'm
sharon's aaron
and i'm aaron sharon's erin oh
and i'm not sharon
i'm aaron sharon and i'm not sharon
we're not sharing any more air time with
you either
nice um so uh what was i gonna say oh
yeah when they kiss
you went upstairs and kissed and it just
was like 45 seconds
so you have it it sounded like wow it
sounded like a snail
crawling along someone's like stomach
yeah
also i love how sharon aaron was like
you know
up until this point he was like yeah
it's quite chewed it's like whatever i'm
getting to know and then as soon as like
it kind of shook up he just like
bee-lined to her he's like
i want this no but they actually they're
my favorite couple right now
same yeah they're weirdly like
everything they say vibes they just you
can tell there's a spark here
this is definitely gonna last yeah at
least at least a few days
yeah at least until the next recoupling
exactly when another sharon pulls up
oh [ __ ] man copy right up there well
we can just you know
just
oh sharon
[Music]
[Music]
stop it you spit all over me again
of course it was do you have so much how
do you even produce this much saliva
let me show you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i've put two cloves of garlic in my
mouth and making my mouth sweat
i just ate a really hot ghost pepper
i've eaten 14 skittles
sour skittles yeah and i burned my
tongue off yeah i'm probably
my mouth is probably salivated all right
so back to hot guy behavior
yeah brad um pieing off
fear can we run this fast
so we not pause so he re so he lands a
beer pong shot and it says kiss the
person you like the most
and then kiss the person you like the
least and at this point he's coupled up
with faye yeah so bam here it goes
brad hottest guy in the island is being
told to choose who's he's most at least
interested in
let's see if he decides to hurt
someone's feelings
jake on the sidelines watching him brad
goes for the entry
brad walks right up to he's interested
in chloe chloe
right on the lips keep in mind folks
he's currently coupled up with faye
who is looking pretty awkwardly at this
brad completely [ __ ] oh and then he
goes in and he goes right in
oh then just pecks it's just oh that was
an air jab bro yeah
he didn't even it's just like a chloe's
just soaking that in too
yeah she's like oops oopsies
sorry faye oops
do you see that hey
faye she's not listening faye
hey i love how my one of my favorite
things about this show is how like some
people just
totally fade to the background and that
just aren't part of like
anything anything like jake was like one
of the main parts of the first three
episodes and then his story lines became
not that cool
yeah and so then they just edit them out
of the show yeah because love is not
that
interesting yeah but no but he's not but
he keeps like
he wasn't that interesting until until
the spoiler that coveted
ass bust that was the best yeah this is
so funny let's
let this rip man you got all these clips
on deck i'm impressed
chat's going really well they're
laughing she's like i've never connected
with a guy like this ever before my life
hold up it's a pretty big moment right
pretty big moment so then
he goes in for a cheeky snog
friday
[Music]
that's why you cannot wear pants that
tight that
forced his gut out just or in just
i feel like he did i feel like he did it
on purpose
look at that [ __ ] just that smile
he's giving right there he's he knows
what he's about to do
i mean you play it again
just so you get the tune right yeah dawg
i got a hilarious flashback right now
what i can't even say it man
but wait the best part of this is that
he goes you can chew on that
yeah yeah he's like bro
way to make that white one oh my god
i'm dying sorry i'm dying for two
reasons
you ever you ever let one rip during i
don't think during
ever i've said i've had a blumpkin
before if that's what you're no i'm
kidding
i've had i've had diarrhea but like
farting's totally normal like it's
expected almost
it's actually weird if you don't fart
during a bumpkin there's something wrong
it's like why aren't you [ __ ] and
farting is something wrong oh no it's
not like i usually i shouldn't fart
all while getting the blonde is it bad
or something
no it's great normally i'd be [ __ ]
all over the place like i could feel it
i want to [ __ ] everywhere
but i just i can't for some reason it's
like i'm sorry it's not working
i'm stressed it's just my mind's in
another place right now
next day how was last night
it's all right i went in for the blumkin
but he wasn't [ __ ] piss everywhere
hmm that's weird was he farting at least
no he didn't fart at all he didn't [ __ ]
or fart no did he crap at all
no no grabbing crapping not a little bit
wow
did he not even one turd no but you know
what what
he snuck to the bathroom later oh yeah
and i think he was doing it himself
you think he took a [ __ ] by himself yeah
really
as quite hurt my feelings honestly
that's not cool
because i thought it was like you know
we're in the hideaway
that's brad yeah yeah i can do this
better yeah
she like she's going in on it and i say
you're not [ __ ]
get me [ __ ] while you're sucking me off
so in the middle of the night right i'd
go and i [ __ ] myself
ah yeah anyways